and that's like one of the
misconceptions I feel like it's in it's
him
you found the moment my nose is dripping
let's go
this is really spicy
oh my
God so okay oh oh wow that camera is
very close I had my dream trip to
Thailand it's always been sort of my
bucket list thing to eat my way through
Thailand and it was seriously The Best
Time Ever circling back I'm here in LA
with my friend Justin who is an amazing
Amazing Thai Chef we're gonna start off
the day by getting an inspirational meal
we're gonna go get lunch at Justin's
favorite Thai spot then we're gonna go
explore some Thai ingredients at a
market and then Justin and I are doing a
Thai Taco Tuesday at his restaurant on a
job super fun concept that Justin
created during the pandemic I haven't
ever cooked with Justin I know he's an
amazing chef
so it will be really fun I have a great
group of friends joining us we have
Molly boss Vanessa Lombardo jet Tila
really interested in seeing what they
think about our tacos let's go eat some
spicy food
[Music]
we're here
it looks so good oh my God I can't wait
[Music]
I can barely see him with his tinted
windows
what's up Chef how are you
so we're meeting me yeah yeah I'm so
excited to do this I'm excited too yeah
it should be it should be cool mark
means was here so it must be amazing
what's the spiciest thing
um I'm gonna say these the Jackfruit
salad last time I cried what that was it
was so cool what is how's your how's
your spice tolerance
medium
medium no it's medium I'm just trying to
be real I'm trying to be realistic I'm
not don't be too Brave coming into this
place guys come in with a humility and a
sensitive stomach and a lot of antacids
do not get Brave hello
um
I like variety you like variety yeah
okay I heard getting backseat menu
managed right now yeah it's like a real
Thai spicy no but like real
real okay yeah perfect perfect yes you
can handle it yeah come on Chef I feel
like a lot of these very authentic
places can be intimidating for people to
like try out like this strip mall has
like four different restaurants like how
do you know which one to go to I think
there's a sense of No Frills in in the
presentation and and and and in this you
know I mean so like all of the effort
has gone into
this kosoi Lao long bean salad
which is pork stewed with tomato and
usually to announce which looks really
spicy the Jackfruit salad
oh wow like a lot of herbs it's like a
one-to-one uh pork to Herb ratio
Northern Thai food it's very herbaceous
I mean it's a very pork forward yeah
Cuisine but there's a lot of flavors and
it's very spicy I would say leaning on
the sour salty definitely oh the
lemongrass
oh
um
that's still good it's a very mild very
mild spice balance some of these things
may not be on the enjoyable side you can
see there's a lot of chilies it's mainly
chili
but I've had it this year
I know you're the host of the show and
all this and you gotta look good in
front of your fans to me this would be
like a six or seven right that's
responsible talk to me about Thai spicy
it is a psychological spicy right so
like Chinese spicy like Sichuan spicy
it's warming it's in the Soul Thai spicy
is like someone's slapping you across
the face saying pay attention to me
here's my theory about Thai food thai
people were born into the jungle or they
were born into the city that's in the
jungle your senses are being
bombarded with sounds of birds and
cicadas and
stray dogs and mopeds and like exhaust
fumes and like all the meanwhile while
you're eating something you're getting
like
Kamikaze with [__] mosquitoes by the
way this is not a great advertisement I
love Thailand with that comes a Cuisine
where the flavors have to be so much
higher to overcome the sensory overload
of the Jungle you know this is jungle
food not a lot of like salty or spicy in
this
which is not typical in Thai food thai
food is used in the north it's all about
Sour salty okay in the South it's about
spicy and [__] up thai cuisine was not
originally spicy because chilies were
introduced into Thai Cuisine like 500
years ago by the Portuguese right and
then Thai people appropriated that into
the cuisine and now everyone has the
association five centuries later that
it's spicy old school Thai Cuisine and
Royal Cuisine it's very mild in Royal
cuisine
they're very it's very sweet and very
subtle because it's sort of un uncourt
like to be sweating in front of your
princes and stuff right ground pork with
tomato chili dip this is like a Thai
Bolognese yeah closest you can oh my God
just throw pasta in there yeah serious
and this is is this typically spicy
roasted chili dip typically it's only
with green chilies they put in red
chilies here
because they want to [__] with us I'm
sure if this is The Bolognese of Thai
food this would be
like the like a like a like a Mexican
salsa if you will and taste like salsa
yeah they're very raw very it's raw okay
can we talk about tacos please so you've
been doing Thai tacos Tuesday for a long
time yeah since the beginning of the
pandemic oh my guys are in the kitchen
Mexican Guatemalan
Vietnamese oaxacan and I was like let's
use family meals away for us to explore
creativity and I started to do tacos and
the alley was empty at the time and
never thought to serve people in that
alley So Thai Taco Tuesday you know kind
of became a bit of an industry thing all
right
all right inspirational meal complete
I've always wanted to go to go Thai
market in L.A
is there the one we're gonna go to Islam
which is in the heart of of Thai town
okay and it's it's a pretty good size so
I think we'll be able to find some good
stuff all right let's do this thing
[Music]
foreign
I know
[Music]
did you bring your wallet of course I
probably want it we're going shopping
um this is what I like to do take inspo
from the markets what is this this is
just straight up weed
it says holy basil oh okay well so then
these are the chilies that we were
probably just having a bunch of yeah and
then you have the mix between the green
and the red and then just the red okay
so what is the difference
yes less ripe less spicy more like sort
of you know Green flavor yeah if you
will I like the mix because it makes the
chili sauces look really cool
should we get more
Red Thai Chili because I want to make a
really crazy okay yeah let's do it let's
do it oh and I love this what's that
this is a Sawtooth coriander oh yeah I
love it yeah yeah it's like great strong
cilantro it's cilantro on steroids yeah
so you have this the mustard let's get
some let's get some I don't have any
right now oh this is a snack aisle I
want to work for lays in Thailand
because they have like they have the
best flavors so oh they have tom yum oh
yeah oh let's try that yeah all right so
what are we gonna make we'll figure that
out no this is
which is like a red style chili paste
it's got like you know like grilled fish
in it and this one is really epic it has
Green Mango in it but also rice roaches
what is that Rice Patty right right
literally like they look like giant bugs
that freaks me out a little bit though
take a look you want to see a picture of
mangda yeah let's see it the wings of
these roaches are so big that the meat
underneath the wings tastes like
scallops hey I've had water bugs before
leftocera's indicus Gnar but they kind
of have like the aroma of um like a
watermelon Jolly Rancher what believe it
or not
stopping what are you talking about this
is the ingredient 2024 ingredient of the
Year rice paddy roaches oh my God all
right we feel good
foreign
[Music]
a half to service and we don't even have
a menu so
Justin is nowhere to be seen hello
everything's going to be spicy
everything okay can I write the quick
menu all right we're going to do a
popcorn
Lobster
taco right yeah we're doing a popcorn
Lobster Taco with a chili crisp and a
soy aioli and then we'll do a Thai
crayons trip loin Taco with a pickled
mustard salsa are we using this for
marinade you should toss it in the
marinade it's great
wow that's first I mean I know how it
smells
oh but I like to just share the moment
you know it would be good with this
popcorn Lobster it's like a really
crispy papaya salad could be kind of
good at the bottom too we have an hour
no we have an hour and a half yeah yeah
no we have an hour so it's just like
Iron Chef
yeah I don't even have a knife so I'm
gonna eat good
I did in Thailand I did a lot of grilled
Meats when I was there pulling from my
background and what I normally cook and
also like what I did in Thailand and
some of like what we shop for and ate
today
I'm gonna make I'm gonna get started on
trying to buy a salad but I'm gonna be
over there we're going to be using these
Thai chilies that we got
and some garlic
hey Chef can you make extra of that so I
can take a spoonful and put it in my
marinade yeah I'm gonna put some fresh
chilies in here too because it's
spicy I'm like scared to taste it why
not
that's a very interesting flavor it's
like a little sweet but it's like it has
something that I can't identify and I
think that's the bug that's the manga
yeah
hers looks better though
oh my God this thing is good Chef do you
feel good
um yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't want to
lose lose to who you we were competing
we are now we're definitely competing
you're a very competitive person
well I don't lose Molly bass is coming
tonight
we're gonna have their names right here
right
Jet right here and then uh and your
friend Vanessa labrado
okay cool yeah I haven't met her she
seems cool based on the name we just
passed in uh some snap peas has like a
really sweet crunch to it and then we
got
um we have kumquats which is also not
traditional I like
it adds like a nice
it's spicy
I'm proud of you made it spicy let's
just like she wants a little bit more
you know we are heat eaters
all right which one's for a hit let's do
more heels do you want to taste this
marinade whoa this looks amazing
[Music]
I made it really strong because it we
only have an hour and a marinade so
that's it's not that well that's gonna
be great here's the trick to getting the
mangoes correct you let them sit in your
hot Prius that has no tint and you drive
around Los Angeles for three days and at
the end of that they taste exactly how
they need to taste
we have half an hour Chef okay
ready let's do this thing
I see
why is this a battle all of a sudden
so this is it
is it that looks amazing I mean I don't
know
um
I think it used to be spicier
I'm gonna have more chilies
right
well that's pretty damn good it's great
[Music]
hmm
wow
that's really good you've made some
tacos in your life
I'm Molly how are you how are you doing
good to see you
thanks for coming welcome back to the
alley am I not supposed to I mean
I'm so hungry oh God
hi Vanessa how are you doing thank you
so much this is your first time meeting
welcome to the alley hey what's going on
hey what's up cousin oh are you guys
really cousins uh it makes you nervous
why is everything a competition to you
we'll start you off with just some some
tostadas first and then we're gonna say
more and then our our tacos will go head
to head oh it is not a competition
all right
competition talking yeah
chefs what do we have what do we have
Maine Lobster tempura on papaya salad
and a little bit of chili crisp that we
make here
and some magrute uh Lime Leaf on top oh
nice and so we have a you guys are
giving it away
okay so what's in this okay so this
played it's a Thai Korean barbecue oh
God gave it away whatever Thai Korean
barbecue with a mango and pickled
mustard salsa yum with lots of crispy
things on top okay and what are the
crispy things besides shallots because I
can see what those are
listening is that a crispy crispy rice
okay
okay whoa drip factor yes okay as far as
like Thai Spice you want more I can
always do more yeah so I didn't make
this that chili curse we make this one
was brought to me by a friend and that
one's really special I'm like we're not
allowed to use so much of it because
it's that hot it's really hot okay you
want to try yeah I do yeah yeah yeah go
there babe we're not scared all the way
around
I mean it's sweaty I mean it's not like
killing me but that's a good signs
it's hitting me cheers yeah Cheers
Cheers Cheers we did it we did it
they're both so delicious you guys and
they're great compliments to one another
if I do say so
like was there something that was
revelatory or like in the way that
Justin Cooks food or Thai people cooking
food because you've been to Thailand
it's a lot of on unfamiliar territory
for me because Koreans don't use a lot
of herbs and spices like it's very kind
of have more fermented flavors but with
Thai food like herb heavy we went to
um northern Thai food I've never had
Regional Northern Thai food so it was
like a new experience for me like lots
of herbs like in your face it's a sassy
spice yeah
well balanced and that's like one of the
misconceptions I feel like about typhoon
that's like Christmas is so good you're
doing good though you found the moment
yeah your nose is dripping Moment of
Truth okay give it to us all right
should we continue I'm sure it wouldn't
though I'd be like you know you whisper
can I whisper
have you been winning or losing more
I lose all the time you guys no time to
win just once what
they're playing games again did you guys
have a preference can you go away
guys
but out wow okay listen linger much as
far as all right there's no way because
it's seriously there's no way they found
like Beauty on both sides both tacos I
think it's really hard to call one Thai
food is balanced it is balanced the
eating experience holistically with the
two of them was special like it was in
good balance they're better together
yeah
Justin doesn't want a part of this you
guys discussed
[Music]
Expressions had really good spice the
lobster was cold
I'm sorry Esther Ma
and this one Lobster temperature let's
see which one she likes more I like it I
mean but between the two yeah if you
have to pick one
[Music]
oh
you got Mom with a man
I lost one zero
[Music]
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching oh God that was
spicy
please like And subscribe and to watch
more episodes click here